hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the pain train that
is condemned sorry again for missing
this people are telling me that that was
like the best jump scare the game now I
feel bad I'm real really bad for missing
it but oh well that's just the way it be
whoa okay I like how on the UH the tips
screen it just said for me to look for
health kits and that's all hey look it's
my apartment
hey yeah I thought the police were
tearing that apart investigate my mind
in my instincts are flaring up okay ah
not the reading here we go get this
handprint in here click right there come
on take a picture of it
there we go click click and Eliza baby
let me know what you think
thank you you search all of those
databases instantaneously wow that is
impressive
alright so anyway that taken care of now
we just yeah
frequency NL ah nice time to save a
checkpoint what was that
what was that huh god dammit oh no
you're the guy that's the guy
Oh after you buddy no block pass it
block what come on block you do what
oh whoa hello hi
didn't I just smash your skull in uh man
this sushi that sledgehammer is not good
for fighting how cute this is you make
me feel like a badass like a badass yeah
you want some good think so yeah I
thought that was the guy oh wait where
do you go oh no where where do you go oh
here we go
uh-huh oh how I'm going to get you don't
you hurry I'm going to smash your seat
hello is anybody out there through there
nope
run like you the policeman that I am I'm
glad things finally started to get a
little creepier oh look at this bird I
think I'll pick that up yeah yeah that's
good idea I'd like that
I like me a dead bird every once in a
while I might actually get all six just
weird
ah good Wow you startled me
you startled me
whoops there we go a brain here nope
okay
sometimes I liked it the way that this
game the animation of this game of how
it makes you feel like you move what the
hell is going on oh what the hell what
what oh man this guy and birds are not
doing well this guy is right yo come
here pass through the door to complete
the chapter oh I missed a bird hang on
maybe maybe there'd be one more bird
over here you never know you never know
there isn't one is there is a lie
there's a dirty lie burden the trash can
no bird on the bench no bird under here
duck under wait a minute can I go back
I'm confused here
let me see something I just want to see
real quick oh no this leads back to
where I came from that's right I came
from over here but here's the crowbar
probably better than a sledgehammer
anyway and I'll probably need a crowbar
in the next area cuz you know how this
game is alright lemme I'm sorry whammy
yeah god I cannot spread for anything
alright this is jet on out of here
excuse me whammy
I earned this year of three metal pieces
I don't even know what these metal
pieces are I'm supposed to look for
favorite weapon pumps shotgun hell yeah
I hope I get more I hope I get more guns
soon because melee is fun but it's not
very effective but my crowbar go dang it
my crowbar macro bar so I'm gonna get
this is very fast
Wham dead bird yay my favorite what
don't be doing that
don't be with the random strange noises
I'll subway always a good thing
a lot of the elements in this game do
remind me of some of the things I've
seen in crime here which obviously it
means a cry fury inspiration from if
anything I'm not saying that it did but
you know a subway in a does not
correlate to the same thing I'm just
saying they're similar I didn't I'm not
saying I'm not saying than any dress
right I'm not I'm not saying that I'm
not saying that hey see you see you
there he is follow him I'm an explorer
okay cuz he's gonna wait for me you know
Wow Wow where did you come from
give me that gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme
haha what do you do now whoa what who
did that
you oh boy hello that's been see where
are you where are you where you where'd
you go where'd you go
come on bring it come here come here
come here come here I got a friend I got
it I got a present for you I know that I
can have cross hairs by the way I just
what the hell what the hell
hey what Wow oh come on er yeah how were
you out of bullets were you zero fun
forget that I do want more guns
eventually but oh yeah that's what is a
- oh wait no plus magazines fire really
I'm about I am about actually you know
what spark let's do smart AHA that
crosshair feels so intelligent like a
base
how that detract from the realism I like
it I like it better off just because it
kind of feels better it feels weird with
that reticle up there I thought we'd
take that Dave are you dead whoa whoa
whoa flashing lights oh my goodness
all right moving forward up whoop yeah I
see you oh that's it what's that buddy
what's it what about it your head shout
oh oh you were gonna hit him oh I
shouldn't let you what are you doing you
threw away your weapon
but why he's had a perfectly good one oh
that is a weird face what I are dead
[Music]
okay because this lad to me I thought I
was suing the x2 meant two clips left
judo judo slam how about yeah that's
good oh oh now you go down just like
that really do the gun whoa hello
what gun what was that who was that why
was that who huh huh I'm confused I am
confused
ah hello what what why things are
getting weird I feel bad for the people
that live around here because being
around these crazies whoa hello hi
what okay then how about you take uh you
don't have get away get away get away
get away get away what the hell honey
you couldn't do anything to do that 11 I
was wrong oh sorry I was gonna go I
should have done she move oh ha ha ha
what'd you do
that's right you gonna die imma grab
this sign I want a fight with a sign
hell yeah
probably bad idea but hell yeah ah take
that with a sign how you like me now oh
you don't
good seriously who fights with this sign
[Music]
well this looks lessened Firex
that over sign sorry I should have
smashed through that with my fist just
didn't you like it
yeah hey whoa whoa whoa where'd you get
a shotgun why didn't you use it not okay
for oh there's another med kit in here
I'm gonna use that's like I get startled
more in this game at the points where
I'm not really supposed to be starts
just someone jumping around a corner or
something like that then actual scares
in this game I got a shotgun who wants
to mess with me huh huh huh yeah didn't
think so far oh come on oh come on
really Maius with my faith all right
here we go all right now go back to the
shotgun but first let's take a breather
from that intense run from here to there
that's was that was something else
now who wants some
hello dead bird hi hi friend
what
who was that does someone come out from
behind me who is that oh that's a what
done wait a minute wait a minute what's
going on oh come on I would have a
crowbar if you let me keep one from the
beginning how about a kick to the perks
no one shot okay go heal up just worth
changing out for how many bullet you got
five not bad
take that this way
Hiskey Piske Oh actually I'm Way over
time sorry I'm completely out of time
sorry I lost track of that anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more Let's Plays that
I've done in the reaction compilation
below and as always I'll see you in the
next video